all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts over morning
coffee um today I'm going to be talking
about why I actually don't think it
matters if you're married or not to give
marriage and relationship advice now
before I start I'd like to say on this
channel that's not typically um what I
do so don't misconstrue is that is me
saying you should listen to me about it
but what I wanted to say is
what I realized when I first got into
the manosphere I would hear Kevin
Samuel's
talk and something about the way he
spoke it just rung like true to me and
it some of it was triggering some of it
I denied at first but I would just
listen to Kevin Samuel's talk and I
thought a lot of what that man says is
correct um whether I like it or not but
Kevin Samuels had been divorced three
times
and I began to question maybe people
shouldn't listen to him I me he's
divorced right and I'd like to
say why it doesn't
matter um because for a relationship to
be in order it needs two things the man
has to run it and the woman has to look
up to the man and desire him and want to
be with him the man also needs to want
to be with her but it's not nearly as
important and what you realize is there
are men that have been married 20 30 40
50 years that have been letting their
wife run the relationship for a
lifetime and so what I found is that
typically the people that are more
humble about it like the people that you
know say this is just what worked for
me tend to be better relationship
coaches and give a little bit more
practical advice where the ones that are
like
they it's weird they almost make their
them being like married part of their
brand it it's it's completely weird and
you'll see it like Matt Walsh's wife did
this to me where she's like I've been
married 10 years and I'm thinking like
sorry she seems nice but I'm like
lady I know people that have been
married 20 30 40 years and I would not
trade places with them because they are
so
miserable and that's the tough thing is
until you learn to like pick out what
makes a relationship look in
order you really don't know how to tell
the difference so when you're
younger you know you have people like
Matthew hussy giving advice now Matthew
Huss is getting
married he's probably going to stay
married but Kevin Samuels probably gave
better advice than Matthew
hussy you know Steve Harvey gave like
the worst advice
ever and um yeah Steve Harvey gave the
worst advice ever and he was married so
it's really confusing out there who to
listen to and who to not listen to um
obviously this doesn't mean everyone but
a couple things that I noticed of how to
tell a relationship is in order more
traditional um one is does he have to
ask his wife for permission to do things
or can he just do it you know I had a
tweet go viral earlier this year where I
said let me ask my wife wife with like a
barfing
emoji that like to me the equivalent of
that is let me ask my
child let me ask my child what we're
going to do because you know you could
talk to her but really and truly the
final decision has got to be on the guy
and the the second thing is could he
move across the country say upro I'm
going to uproot my entire life I want
you to come with me will she just say
okay I support support you and I trust
you okay another one another one when
they ask the couple's questions who
answers does she answer or does she look
to him to
answer is the house decorated how he
wants it or how she wants it do they eat
the food that he likes or that she likes
and so it's like interesting because
you'll have these people relationships
are an interesting
like they're interesting point of life
because you'll have people that maybe
were married 20 30 years
but I I mean you can't say it's
unsuccessful if they're still married I
guess but I don't think most people
would envy it if the woman's running the
relationship um because what you see
with those guys is they become a shell
of themselves they really become like
little you know little just
you know and I don't say this in
a happy way but you know this is why you
know that that point it's really just a
moot point it's really not about that
you know the question is is the
information correct and when I first got
into you know the manosphere stuff I
would listen to like Donovan
sharp and I thought he was kind of nuts
like he would tell me things you know he
he had this course called like womanese
and when she says this she means that
and I was like you're kind of
overthinking it Donovan that do doesn't
mean anything whatever couple years
later I had to get some like real life
experience you know interviewing chicks
interviewed a thousand women paying more
attention to what women do versus what
they say and honestly Donovan was right
like you know when a girl says you're
such an he
said that means she wants to screw you I
was like no maybe he's just a dick and I
was like then I find out women love
dicks we love but the problem
is like we live in this delusion like
most women don't live in reality so
we'll hear things that are completely
true but we're so self-centered that
we're not really paying attention to the
world we're paying attention to
ourselves until at 37 reality hits Us in
the face you know what I mean um but
yeah this is why I want to talk about
dating
coaches I honestly think I have gotten
more useful information from divorced or
single men not women women are just
going to lead you down to destruction
typically then I've gotten from married
men dating coaches that's the crazy
thing like I probably got more useful
information from single men versus from
Married Men because most married men are
kind of
I'm sorry they're going to cck
clip it I don't care most of them
are because they didn't they won their
train of thought was always what she
wanted so they're always thinking what
she wants how she feels when really the
guy has to think about himself first we
hate it when you think about us
first I mean we might complain but you
know we hate it deep down um and so a
lot of married guys just want want to
get the first girl that they can find
and just you know go to church marry her
and from what I've seen that doesn't
really work even if they stay married
you know the guys are kind of feminine
you know and I don't you know mean this
in a rude way but even like I watched
Matt Walsh and his wife in Iraq they're
cute I hope they stay together
but you know she looks like she runs
that relationship that's how it appears
to the viewer um Ben Shiro you know he
he talks about
how uh what did he say he said you know
he'll always brag about his wife his
wife's a doctor and then he'll also say
like I begged like she wasn't ready to
go out with me and I had to basically
convince her for a couple
months oh that's a bad sign now I'm not
saying they might stay together I don't
know but that's still out of order
that's out of order women are happiest
when we're obsessed with you not the
other way around we don't like it when
the men are obsessed with us
and truly if a Girl Wants To Be With You
she'll get on a plane she'll get on a
boat she'll she'll do anything she'll
get there um to be with you
so the problem is such in my opinion
such a small percentage of marriages and
relationships are in order because most
of us were not raised um to do that most
of us were not raised to be wives not
raised to be mothers not raised to be
masculine fathers so none of us really
know what we're
doing
so I mean that's my opinion on it okay I
think the best dating coaches are single
men I really
do
um the non simpy ones there's a lot of
simpy ones too though so you know uh but
let me know what you guys think um
discuss in the comments these are just
my unfiltered thoughts I could be wrong
like the video on your way out subscribe
I'll talk to you next time